100 días de Lula da Silva al frente de
Brasil significan 100 días del
expresidente Jair bolsonaro como Némesis
natural del gobierno el actual
mandatario no desperdició la oportunidad
de recordarlo en su discurso de
conmemoración de esta primera etapa de
gestión
Todos siempre digo que si sumas todos
los presidentes de la República desde la
proclamación de la República hasta estas
elecciones la suma de todas las
candidaturas juntas no gastó lo que
gastó este ciudadano en la perspectiva
de perpetuar El fascismo en el país
Lula Busca dirigirse como garante de la
Democracia frente a su predecesor
especialmente a raíz del asalto de Los
Seguidores del ultraderechista bolsonaro
a las sedes del Congreso la presidencia
y el tribunal supremo a inicios de año
el ataque más violento a los poderes
brasileños en décadas
[Aplausos]
armonía
Brasil volvió a cultivar la armonía y la
convivencia republicana entre los tres
poderes de los cuales el mayor ejemplo
fue la rápida reacción al intento de
golpe de estado del 8 de enero al día
siguiente de la barbarie los tres
poderes marcharon juntos del Palacio de
Gobierno del plan alto al tribunal
supremo pasando por el Congreso Nacional
para decir alto y claro no al fascismo
Sí a la democracia
pero el asalto del 8 de enero también
demuestra la amplia base que todavía
ostenta bolsonaro el expresidente Volvió
el 30 de marzo a Brasil después de un
exilio auto impuesto en Estados Unidos
asegura que no quiere liderar ninguna
oposición pero a la vez afirma que
quiere seguir haciendo política sin
embargo Lula también cuenta con el apoyo
del 41% de los brasileños que consideran
que su gestión ha sido buena o excelente
frente a un 24% que la valoran como mala
o pésima unas cifras que hablan de un
Brasil todavía dividido